i guess uh do you want to talk about the
thing that all three of us have been
wanting to ask
yeah i i i mean as an animator on
twitter and everything like that
opinion matters yeah your opinion your
opinion your opinion matters
our opinion doesn't mean [ __ ] your
opinion on the other hand it means a lot
yeah
like how do you feel about you know
artists and animators getting backlash
after an episode has aired for example
attack on titan yeah i'm going to say it
for some reason people are very very
angry and have been sending even
death threats yeah just like directors
and animators on twitter and stuff like
that
does that scare you or anything like
that working on projects well if i had
those kind of
threats it would be oh i messed up but
no no no no you should actually
in my case if i it's just twitch or
internet i
don't have time to bother about that i
have to concentrate in my drawings
exactly so yeah but for people who gave
all the guts didn't sleep managed to
to deliver the episode and receive all
the stretches
it's a bit it's not very hard enough
to deal with threats yeah and hard work
yeah and i think that most of you
animators nodes are working ah i i
couldn't
do this good well but i managed to
reverse the episode and i know their
level and they want to progress too good
yeah yeah everybody wants to do a good
episode want to make a
quality yeah right but you have to
manage it
with the amount of schedule the amount
of money
and it's uh yes it's very hard and
sometimes you
in animation a good
schedule a good something going well
doesn't exist
animation you have a lot of problem
teeny problems you have to adjust
right it's not just like the problem of
like you know the single animator yeah
it's like there's a lot of things that
the animator probably has to juggle but
like
if i like you know but say for example
like i i would maybe understand a little
more if even the animator
looked at what they did and was like
yeah that wasn't my best work
but this is a tag on time we're talking
yeah and it's been pretty amazing so far
have you been following the episode of
attack on yes i have watched the last
one
yeah and people uh for some reason are
very vocal that like oh it's terrible
now the animation quality is terrible
most of the people don't like the cgi i
think yeah yeah
and yeah if you are used to uh something
that you wish that you have done
with this quality yeah and now it's uh
we say actually me too when i see oh
this isn't
a job well i'm a bit i prefer it it was
or more on sakura
yeah i i understand yeah but but you can
say that because you're in there
right i understand that most of some of
them you say oh
i would prefer sakuga but it's not a
reason to
to yeah unlike people like the show is
ruined
the cgi has ruined my show and it's like
what what do you mean
it's so bizarre but like people are also
complaining about some of the sakura as
well really
yeah i've been seeing that like you know
some some i've seen some people on
twitter have been awesome yeah no but
some people on twitter have you know
like done comparisons with like the
manga panels for example um
it's completely ruined it's not exactly
the same right like how do you feel
about stuff like that
they push too much yeah because because
i've always wanted because you've worked
on
some pretty high profile shows my hero
had this problem as well
i had this problem a lot do you ever
like when working on it do you ever like
feel the pressure whenever you're
working on a big ip
need to and want to deliver actually um
i know that
most of the when i post something
of my gengar in twitter is
not my animation they have likes it's
more the the
the ip has likes right i think people
don't i don't know most of the people
like put the like or the retweet oh but
because it's my
i like this ip yeah no because
i think i saw the animation that you did
for that yes uh
yeah i love that's like literally like
the best fight in part four like
so good and it was amazing oh man it was
so hard to this
because it was uh yeah it was in 2008
yeah yeah it was christmas and i spent
all my christmas and new year at working
at the studio
i spent three weeks at sleeping in the
studio to finish the first three weeks
sleeping at the studio yeah
yeah just for the pashy fight uh because
i had to finish the hiroakia
layout and after hiraka had my uh wait
so you were working on the hiraka layout
while you're working on the jojo again
yeah i when i finished to hirocam
jojo came back and
uh and the deadline was of like the 10th
of january
and so most of my co-workers went to
was was a tiago so most of it was in
french people so they went back to
france i spent the new year
and and they came back and just when
they
went to france it was i had no beer and
when they came back i had a
big beer they just haven't left
and so i was going to uh
a gold gym to have my shower oh my god
so that must have been like the case
where like if you were there
all the time you're probably like were
you just thinking about it in the shower
as well you're like
thinking about what you were going to
draw next as well yeah but
i'm sure it takes time but sometimes you
can
eat yours may smell bad i have to take a
shower or
so but optimize your showers it's just
like do you ever get to the point when
you're just like eating
too much time so i was eating watching
an episode eating and okay if the
episode finished i have
finished to eat okay go back to work
you're welcome jojo fans
and so yes yeah i get sick also
i i think i had him he's a bad one or i
have a
infringer how do you say you're an
influencer yeah i get infringement
[Music]
i was working like that literally
killing yourself for jojo fans
uh you could say you were
yeah yeah i think you can say i was
trying to do my best on
this one i i think a lot of people would
argue that's one of the best fight
scenes in part five
yeah right yeah it looks amazing as well
yeah i think
all of part five everyone could tell i'm
just saying that because you're here
like i said uh uh animations it's a
teamwork
yeah so like i said i do the rough
animation after the
the director put some correction so
something that was a too little
how can i say oh you can push more this
arm
the director will put it and after the
the
director of animation will put the mod
more
in model right and so these three tabs
are very important after
i receive this correction i redraw it
everything with all the details all the
shadows
all the lights all the perfect frames so
yes it's a teamwork and after this
drawing it will be the
in-betweener who will clean up yeah and
right between it's a very a teamwork
it's not just one animator's work is you
have the
direct the director of animations in
between the color um
i'm curious this may be a dumb question
uh do you like hear
so when you're drawing it i assume is
the voice acting recorded at that point
or is it not recorded
no it's it's tough way after oh wow
voice acting is post production yeah oh
wow
so you don't even get to like hear the
lines as you're drawing or anything
sometimes you have uh some um a rough
voice right
right but it's not the final voices yeah
it's mostly it's mostly just like
i think it's written out in the layout
section right of yeah
actually what they're going to say in
this particular the storyboard the
storyboard and after you have the time
sheet
when at this moment you have to ha
oh and then the voice actors match that
yeah yeah so all anime is dubbed anime
yeah it is dumb yeah wow
checkmate check made self-elitish